not a dissimilar question in a way but
um this time it's
regarding whether a person can donate
something from his body donate blood in
this case is that allowed during the
fast when a person donates blood it's
somewhat like cupping cupping means
removing blood from the body to the
surface either by sucking or by cupping
it is somewhat similar as far as this is
concerned there is difference opinion
among the scholars can you donate blood
or is cupping allowed while fasting or
can a person cup there's a Hadith which
is mentioned in Sun Abu da volume number
two in the book of fasting Hadith number
2364 where a beloved Prophet Muhammad
Salli wasallam said anyone who cups and
gets
CED they break their fast is a person
who
cups and a person who gets
CED breaks the fast but there's also
another Hadith inkari number three in
the book of fasting number
1938 where it's mentioned that Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam was CED while
fasting now because of these two Hadith
the difference opinion in the scholars
there's one group of Scholars who say
that because mammad sallallah Ali
wasallam gave a
Commandment that the person who gets CED
and the person who cups he breaks the
fast
cupping is prohibited blood donation is
prohibited the other Hadi is an action
the first Hadith is a commandment so
when a commandment and action if it
crashes the Commandment has got more
value So based on this there is a group
of Scholars who say that blood donation
is Haram amongst these Scholars we have
Imam Ahmed hbal we have she binas who
says that cupping and blood donation is
Haram we have the great scholar Shi who
says it's Haram shik
Sal fan and shik jiin all of these
Scholars says cing is Haram and Sh jiin
says that if a person donates blood it's
like cupping therefore it's Haram but if
he does it to save somebody's life it is
permissible but yet it breaks the fast
and he has to make up for that fast
later on now there's another group of
Scholars where Alani he says that the
earlier Hadith of Abu da it has been
abrogated
by the Hadi of
sari therefore cing is allowed and
donating blood is allowed so the second
group of schols who say donating blood
is allowed and cing is allowed while
fasting and does not break the fast we
have
Alani we have among the sa Malik may
Allah be pleased with him we have Aisha
may Allah be pleased with her we have
Imam Malik we have IM Shafi so there's
another group of Scholars who say that
blood donating does not be bre the fast
so based on this there are some Scholars
who say it's Mak some Scholars say that
if there's such a large difference of
opinion so if it has to be done avoid it
and do
it after Sunset so we have difference
opinion as far as blood donation is
concerned but as far as the other things
are concerned for example if there's a
small bleeding due to any injury that
does not break the fast there's no
difference opinion in this or if you
take blood only for testing a few mL of
blood is removed from the body for
testing this does not break the fast or
an injury and a cut the blood comes out
doesn't break the fast or if it's a nose
bleed or bleeding of nose it doesn't
break the fast or if it's a minor
surgery a little blood flows out it
doesn't break the fast if excessive
blood flows out in a blood surgery which
is equivalent to blood donation then it
breaks the fast so as far as the second
part is concerned about blood taking out
for testing nose bleed or minor bleeding
there is no difference of opinion all of
them agree that this does not break the
fast